orienté vers le bloc sinon comment vous
c'est à cet acquis fait avoir je tourne
vers la boxe ça lui même te bats c'est
moi benoît blanchard benoît blanchard
seo à saint-ex s'intègre à sa date
ok ça va ça va super couilles tu veux
rentrer ouais ben papa j'en reviens pas
c'est génial mais aussi le feu et sa
fille là ça nous rajeunit pas tout ça
ouais bon en tout cas je suis hyper
chaud chaud de coups bas pour être un
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites là bas on est
venu pour le casting et le casting à
l'ego
[Musique]
ils sont plus de 4 à avoir envoyé leur
candidature
leur point commun être ami avec emma est
belle leur but devenir parrain et
marraine de l'enfant devenir marraine de
l'enfant de ben bas je pense que ça va
me permettre de donner un sens à ma vie
on dit souvent que l'on choisit pas sa
famille mais qu'on choisit ses amis
alors pour moi choisir un parrain s'est
fait rentrer ses amis dans sa famille
s'étaient massés ma meilleure amie donc
je pense que c'est un peu normal
qu'elles choisissent pour être la
marraine ya pas vraiment de débat en
fait si je crois qu'il ya débat en fait
emma et ben vont devoir relever le défi
choisir les meilleurs parrains et
marraines olharan c'est quoi ce truc là
la base ne s'était même pas posé la
question et non s'est pas posé la
question parce qu'on sait pas si on en
veut des pratiques de nos candidats
préparent leurs auditions dans une
ambiance conviviale
je vous montre un truc photo kc au un
ben et moi on est on est assis à côté
parce qu'en fait on est copains quoi
voici irène notre première aspirante
marraine du coup buyema je te rappelle
que je suis ta meilleure amie
si tu me choisit pas eh ben tu peux me
rayer de ta vie voilà mais ce serait
vraiment fini entre nous tu vois voilà
merci mais non merci
autre fait l'heure du café
deux cas pour moi ce tout net irène ne
semble pas avoir convaincu notre jury
hawks mais qu'en sera-t-il de fred notre
prochaine candidate ça lui ferait cadeau
c'est beaucoup c'est un suv en rapport
avec l'enfant je veux pas vous forcer la
main mais je pense que je serai à la
meilleure marraine pour votre enfant à
vous me connaissez je suis sincère
dévoué et puis j'adore les hauts-fonds
[Musique]
pardon en fait ça me rappelle que je
peux pas en avoir et du coup c'est c'est
dur non mais c'est pas sûr peut-être on
sait jamais quoi ok salut merci fred
coup de tonnerre sur le plateau du grand
défi avec cette révélation inattendue
fred pourrait bien toucher le jury en
plein coeur
fa sol la si do salut mec cellules qui
ça c'est cool tu joues bien merci
c'était bien commun benoit tu l'as tu le
meilleur pote de ben regarde ça c'est
une photo de nous en ce1
ça c'est ben et ça c'est moi ok si la
côte est d'accord bon bah merde
et c'est au tour de ludo venu présenter
un numéro un peu spécial bonjour bonjour
mon ami mon ami ben mon meilleur mais tu
tués deux frères que je n'ai jamais
geste mais l'embellie douce et super
vas-y concentre toi non je te lis j'y
arrive pas on répète ça marchait très
bien et pas les caméras
je veux savoir qui c'est benoît non je
crois que c'était moi ton meilleur pote
non mais plutôt mais c'est ça a plus
d'eau ludo ces personnes ce type c'est
vrai
et c'est désormais l'heure du choix pour
notre jury comme le dos de qui et de
ludo irène ans fred ou benoît deviendra
parrain ou marraine le danger de
l'enfant à taux dé marc hé ben non je
suis un peu ça va non tu te crois où
vous vous croyez au 1
alors au final non s'en fiche un parrain
marraine est là si c'est si important
pour vous vous avez qu à tous est
parrain marraine puis voilà maintenant
c'est vrai
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l aventure s'est bien terminée pour nos
candidats
ils vont tous été nommés parrains et
marraines saubenois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]